[Musik]
und wieder ist er unterwegs
auf der suche nach seinem nächsten opfer
[Musik]
in diesem waldstück kommt zuckerberg
streift er herum
erich hauert zweifacher frauenmörder auf
hafturlaub 34 jahre alt
hier lauert er auf sein nächstes opfer
als die 20 jährige pascal brumann
vorbeikommt gibt es für sie kein
entrinnen
der mordfall hat sehr viel bewirkt das
ist so nord wann die täter schwedische
kriminalpolitik der strafvollzug ist
verschärft wurde
man hat angefangen über gemein qualität
anders danke ja es hat auch auf
gesetzesrevisionen als auf den blick vom
strafgesetzbuch ein drastisches niveaus
kaum
[Musik]
die mutter wird diesen samstagmittag nie
vergessen
13 jahre sind seither vergangen
pascal hat die politik und ab macht es
in zollikon ohne echte job gefunden
sie gehe ich in der villa berg das ist
aber sie verbindet und das problem dass
umweltschutz und so sicher ist ihr kiez
und dann ist sie gegangen hatte ich seid
doch bei ihren parteifreunden kommt
pascal nie an
denn auf diesem kurzen waldweg ganz in
der nähe von häusern und straßen trifft
sie auf ihren mörder nach und dann
wieder sehr nervös sie handeln
telefonieren und irgendwo ich es
irgendwie ne nach einer phase die zeit
hat man immer gerne irgendwo eine stufe
und dann half der polizei erlitten
polizei und eltern suchen nach pascal
irgendwo in diesem waldstück ist sie
verschwunden
nach einer langen nacht wird pascal pro
mann am nächsten tag gegen mittag
gefunden
für mich als mord richten schlink sie
will mir dafür griff er hatte bis
gefunden und alle zurück und irgendwie
ich bin nie den wohlstand und ich bin
hier fertig saniert kunde aber
eigentlich nie weg sei dass das boscolo
abregeln wortspiel das ist ja dass das
so dachte ich und ihr könnt wir einfach
mal muss ein wort erwartet worden und
dann teilt mir in meiner kollegen mit
der ökologe nicht einmal waren sie
organe und dann einfach muss stets stand
sagen ja also ich sehe dass ich sie
nicht
das ist wahnsinn so macht das nicht aus
unmittelbarer nähe mit einfach nicht
peter reber ermittler bei der
kantonspolizei zürich erinnert sich noch
genau an jenen tag die frau ich stoppe
den baum stück zu erklären wie deren
natürlicher mode wo motox entdeckt mit
echt und hat nur einen ball vom körper
ist sichtbar sie die arthrose situation
da im wald pletziger am opfer womit sie
hat der polizei fotografen gemacht
typisch britisch name vor elf jahren
2000 und in der waldstück in thalwil das
eben nur 20 jahre gibt studenten wunder
hat die freiheit schwere
schnittverletzungen am hals wie braucht
nur durchschnitt stehen instrument
unterschiedlicher sexualdelikt situation
werde der fundort ab sucht nach spuren
einer sitz hat dann auf fußabdruck spur
gefunden
in der form von spitz zulaufende solle
wo man müsse das sind cowboy stiefel und
wir haben festgestellt dass der 'tatort'
betriebs meter verloren
die probe sie ist wo die frau gebracht
hat
schon am tatort fällt der verdacht auf
erich hauert seine handschrift ist
unverkennbar
doch eigentlich sitzt howard im zürcher
gefängnis regensdorf verurteilt zu einer
lebenslänglichen strafe
[Musik]
an diesem wochenende aber hat er einen
zweitägigen hafturlaub am samstagabend
kehrte ins gefängnis zurück als sei
nichts geschehen
doch schon zwei tage später holte die
polizei dort ab wo zu führen
zu der polizei und hat über projekt das
eine zielperson überprüft und verletzt
sie weiter sichergestellt du sicher
gestellt und hat dann macht eines
internen du dir labortechnisch haben
dann ist ein stück rechtsmedizin braucht
für die medizinische untersuchung am
institut für rechtsmedizin der
universität zürich wird nach beweisen
gesucht
erich hauert hat nach der grausamen tat
seine kleider gewechselt viele spuren
beseitigt doch etwas hat er vergessen
seine armbanduhr
hier finden die spezialisten blut
verdächtige spuren
[Musik]
von wem stammen sie
eine dna analyse liefert den
zweifelsfreien beweis
weil der verdacht so schnell auf
heidfeld kommt er nicht mehr dazu seine
uhr zu reinigen und dann bewies wert
berechnen gemacht tätig so dass die
blutspuren armband 1,3 millionen mal in
der vor der pascal buhmann stand als von
ein anderer unbekannter und verwandte
personen dieser bluttest überführt
howard seien lügen ist nutzlos
er legte ein geständnis ab wie kein
anderes verbrechen löst der mord vom
zuckerberg eine welle der empörung aus
vor allem als bekannt wird
howard ist ein wiederholungstäter
verurteilt zu lebenslänglich zwei frauen
hat er schon umgebracht und jetzt im
hafturlaub morde der wieder sein drittes
opfer
die 20-jährige partie führerin pascal
brumann
[Musik]
der grausame mord an pascal lohmann
bewegt die herzen zollikerberg trauert
alle protestieren sturm gegen die
sinnlose tat die leidgeprüften eltern
sind plötzlich mit fragen des
strafvollzugs konfrontiert mit
gefängnissen und rechtsprechung einer
welt die ihnen fremd ist sie haben ihr
kind verloren und versuchen zu verstehen
das lange zeit nicht können
ich bin immer der ruf aus ich sie wäre
dort gemacht hat was ist übrig geblieben
und der grund nur du so bist dem tag
sind nicht darauf ab noch fertig
bekommen der luft sich sila bislang ist
la bislang nicht eingeschaltet haben das
land bislang nicht 50 jahren könnte man
eine sich nur kurt company und ein hoch
aniko hat da konnten der frühere cruiser
und bitte richter oder respektiere
vorzugs personen und liebe morris dann
hatte noch chancen dass er gottes bild
immer konnte vor
und auch an den fdp-ministern auf
hinterfragen wieso bitte in ihr urlaub
geschickt und mir hand genau dieses
urteil
klasse und dann gefunden aber da ist ein
extrem gefährlicher täter wohne
therapierbar ist und er schnell verwarnt
hat wieso wir zu einem feuer in urlaub
und dann hat immer wieder nachfragen
aber fragen über fragen die antworten
aber die die eltern auf ihre fragen
bekommen sind widersprüchlich und
irritieren jetzt beginnt der lange kampf
der mutter sie sucht nach den wahren
schuldigen
wieso bekam howard hafturlaub wer hat
den tod ihrer tochter zu verantworten
[Musik]
der gefängnisdirektor verteidigt die
urlaubsregelung das sei gängige praxis
auch in allen anderen strafanstalten
verschiedene sicher die 35 punkte
rennklassiker vergrößere die letztlich
da sind sich experten einig bis andere
schweigen der gesetzgeber tatsächlich
will das war nie ruhig war sexualdelikt
gemacht wenn überhaupt nur sachen also
quasi bis zum lebensende wirklich
behalten werden
dann gibt es keine begründung mehr für
ihren urlaub und der vollzugslockerung
justizbeamte psychiater und gefängnis
direktorin entscheiden über hafturlaub
sie alle sind sich keiner schuld bewusst
der hafturlaub soll die gefangenen auf
ihre entlassung vorbereitet
bis zu diesem ort im oktober 93 bedeutet
lebenslänglich bei guter führung 15
jahre zuchthaus das unglaubliche diese
praxis gilt auch für gemeingefährliche
täter wie erich hauert christian
schwarzenegger professor an der
universität zürich hat den liberalen
strafvollzug der 80er jahre untersucht
damals ist mir von der humanistische
grundhaltung ausgegangen dass jede
person zweite oder dritte chance ein
buch das man sie resozialisieren will
dass man alles unternehmen damit sie
wieder gesellschaft zurückkehren
also das heißt dass sperren und
abschlüssen und schlüssel wegschmeißen
so die eu vor sich hat es nicht geht
sondern im gegenteil man hat probiert
möglichst schnell von zugs lokführer wie
spiels wie spring urlaubsland also das
heißt den freigang außerhalb von der
mure mitte zieht vielleicht sogar
übrigen hoffe nicht drauf ausschaut
überführen und auch möglichst schnell
wieder zu einer bedingten classics für
die stimmung ist schon okay dass man
gemeinsam nach wegen schwerverbrechen
irgendwann schon auf der aktiv
einbringen und hat einfach immer
dargestellt und analysiert und
psychologisiert und die therapie
geschickt und ich einfach vom ausgang
generell bringt da jeden wir schon
wieder einigermaßen auf china
bei erich hauert aber hätten die
behörden besser aufpassen müssen denn er
ist ein gemeingefährlicher sexualmörder
bei seiner ersten verurteilung warnt das
gericht ausdrücklich vor seine
gefährlichkeit power zeigt eine abnorme
seelische entwicklung die kaum
therapierbar ist über seine straftaten
spricht er nicht wirkt gelangweilt statt
reue zu zeigen hat er gegähnt harz
blutige karriere beginnt mit knapp 20
jahren in wäldern bei vita parcours und
spazierwegen passt howard seinen opfern
ab
[Musik]
bewaffnet mit einer luftpistole oder
einem messer ausgerüstet mit klebeband
oder sein
meist handelt er nach dem gleichen
muster entwickelt eine art handschrift
er überfällt frauen fesselt sie versucht
sie zu vergewaltigen wird immer brutaler
[Musik]
seine lust ist das quellen
elf frauen hat er so gepeinigt
im april 82 tötet ihr eine studentin
nur acht monate später eine 72-jährige
frau eine grauenvolle serie von
gewalttaten die erst auf führt als er
1983 zum ersten mal verhaftet wird
postbank kunden von der frau wo man
festgestellt hat dass die in 380
innkreis gebracht wurde ist das 27
jährige auf sie setzen liegt
für all diese taten wird erich hauert zu
lebenslangem zuchthaus verurteilt doch
kaum zu glauben nur vier jahre nach
diesem urteil ist er auf hafturlaub
vor diesem allzu lockeren strafvollzug
warnte der damalige oberstaatsanwalt
pius schmid wiederholt die einfachste
generell vorsichtiger sie wie bedingten
entlassungen und sie schnitt nur auf
therapeuten verlage wo deine betreffende
liegt natürlich nahe stand und sie wird
es positiv beurteilen sondern vor allem
landshut gefährlich sind zu uns kleiner
sind
das mit der nano ein externer fachmann
als politisch verantwortlicher geräte
zürcher justizdirektor moritz
leuenberger unter druck
es ist allerschlimmste premium im ganzen
beruf und in einer ganze politische
laufbahn
jetzt handelt der justizdirektor eher
verschärft dass haft regime sofort alle
urlaubssperre soccer city wohnen schon
versprochen haben noch ermittelt
ich muss sagen die richter seien
überreaktionen in so einer show qi das
darf man sich nicht nur vorwerfen dass
ich vielleicht sogar erwartet wurde dass
es zeichen gesetzt wollte nicht und der
neben toni die die dir die frage ja
eigentlich dahinter steckt wie behandle
ich habe der strafvollzug so
organisieren dass mit der gesetze zur
verfügung stellen das internet also
absolut
was muss sich ändern im strafvollzug
diese frage wird zum öffentlichen thema
an dem sich auch jeanette brumann
beteiligt im club trifft sie den
justizdirektor und den gefängnisdirektor
von regensdorf druck vor dem gespräch
heute die sonne norden ist schluss ford
ka news sie hofft dass ihre tochter das
dass die du verräter tun und das über
dank dass das nie verziehen los der tod
jetzt sexy schnitte sowie die andere
viele tote wofür eine triebtäter sondern
das ist eine friedliche und dass man
sein muss etwas passieren und da weder
nochmal halbe jahr wieder griechenland
wiederholen was ich hoffe einfach nicht
passiert also haben wir jetzt wieder
verstärkt als 18 stunden
woher all die fragen woher nahmen die
kraft das die leute mal wieder kleine
sind
ich glaube das ist tochter weil sie
schon so einfach gestrickt und hat sich
eigentlich immer gewehrt für die
schwachen oder das risiko dann nehmen
wir sie in sicherer gaga also das hat
sich doch der alles kann und trotzdem
ist die qualität der also jetzt schon ca
ist getötet worden
ich möchte für meine blumen das risiko
dass sie einander für zum mitdiskutieren
das ist richtig es gibt sie auch
miteinander nach diesem auftritt kippt
die stimmung in der bevölkerung
leserbriefe klagen an frauen und kinder
haben ein recht auf schutz schlamperei
im strafvollzug nicht heilbare
gewalttäter gehören bis an ihr
lebensende hinter schloss und riegel
bevor man wiederholungstäter in
hafturlaub schickt sollte man sie
kastrieren mit dem messerstecher inserat
versucht die svp aus dieser stimmung
politisches kapital zu schlagen
[Musik]
justizdirektor moritz leuenberger wird
immer stärker kritisiert
er ist auf dem sprung nach bern und will
bundesrat werden
da kommen diese vorwürfe höchst
ungelegen
die vorwürfe nachher aus
parteipolitischen gründen das gehört
dazu
das glaub ich hab die unfall mit
heutigen infrastruktur wichtig ist dass
eine insolvent dann verantwortung in der
sache war nimmt und ich hatten in
verschiedener hinsicht das ist das ganze
strafvollzugs natürlich ist ja sehr
verändert wurde leuenberger setzt eine
expertenkommission unter der leitung von
staatsanwalt bärtschi 1
denn howard ist kein einzelfall es gibt
zu viele rückfälle gefährlicher täter
wir sollten in erster linie die
gemeingefährlichen zeit die
berufskriminellen und die touristen im
strafvollzug kritischer führen
kritischer bei der urlaubs gewährung und
bedingte entlassung sein und dann
sollten wir dort wo urlaube gewährt
werden immer bei diesen täter catherine
nicht beieinander
hier sollten wir die urlauber besser
strukturieren und besser kontrollieren
von jetzt an entscheiden externe
fachkommissionen über hafturlaub denn
gemeingefährliche täter können ihre
bezugspersonen allzu leicht täuschen
auch die gefängnis psychiatrie ist im
umbruch
frank urbaniok entwickelt neue konzepte
und therapien für gewalt- und
sexualstraftäter gefährlichkeitsprognose
werden eingeführt
heute hat sich die einsicht durchgesetzt
dass es täte gibt die nicht therapierbar
sind
die nicht therapierbarkeit zeichnet sich
in der regel dadurch aus dass ein sehr
hohes risiko besteht für sehr schwere
straftaten und gleichzeitig das was das
risiko in der persönlichkeit ausmacht
sehr stark verankert ist in der person
kyte meistens sind es lange vor
geschichten und deswegen wenig
ansatzpunkte für veränderungen da sind
zum beispiel jemand der vielleicht
seinen jungen jahren sadistische
fantasien hat und durch das quälen von
menschen erregt wird der schon oft dass
er auf der handlungsebene getan hat der
wenig problem einsicht hat das heißt
eigentlich nicht wirklich das als ein
problem an sieht sich vielleicht
schlecht in andere menschen einfühlen
kann also wenn viele dieser faktoren
zusammenkommen eine zusammenballung von
negativen faktoren
dann ist irgendwann die grenze der nicht
therapierbarkeit erreicht erst jahre
nach dem mord an pascal lohmann geht man
davon aus dass auch erich hauert
zu den nicht therapierbaren tätern
gehört drei jahre nach der schrecklichen
tat kommt es in zürich 1996 am
obergericht zum prozess staatsanwalt
pius schmid klagt auf mord versuchte
vergewaltigung und freiheitsberaubung
noch einmal blickt man auf die
schreckliche tat zurück erich hauert hat
hafturlaub am samstagmorgen ist er in
zürich in der migros am löwenplatz
kaufte er ein messer klebeband und
brötchen
hmm
mit dem elfer tram fährt er in richtung
zollikerberg diese gegend kennt er gut
denn dort besucht er seit längerem seine
psychotherapeutin
die therapie hat im gefängnis angefangen
als sich der psychologe selbstständig
macht darf howard die behandlung in
zollikerberg fortsetzen
auch dafür bekommt er hafturlaub in der
therapie spricht er über seine
schwierige kindheit mit einer langenheim
karriere sein therapeut macht keine
notizen lässt sich täuschen und
unterstützt howard urlaubs besucher auf
seinem 103
hafturlaub passiert ist
in diesem waldstück am zollikerberg
wartet er auf sein opfer
[Musik]
pascal pro mann hat keine chance es ist
offensichtlich dass erich hauert ein
sexualstraftäter ist eher in die
kategorie der serientäter fehlt häufig
handelt es sich bei solchen serientäter
um täter um personen die eine sogenannte
qualifizierte vergewaltigungs
disposition haben das bedeutet sie
empfinden den gewaltsamen die gewaltsame
sexualität als attraktiv als erregend
meistens ist es dann so dass das in der
fantasie immer und immer wieder
durchgespielt wird das eigentlich das
was wir auf der verhaltensebene in den
taten sehen wie die spitze vom eisberg
ist und darunter gibt es stunden
hunderte tausende stunden ihnen das
durch fantasiert worden ist 1996 ist der
strafvollzug bereits massiv verschärft
dort wird für immer hinter schloss und
riegel bleiben das urteil
lebenslänglichem zuchthaus und
verwahrung war ich eigentlich vom
konzept her bis strenger service
gravierend dass er nur im letzten moment
wenn man das mittelmeer hat gesetzt
werden
und es bedeutet da muss man
differenzieren zwischen förder und jetzt
das bedeutet eigentlich das manöver war
gefährlich ist so lang wird in haft ihre
bissig phänomen existiert und dass
hannibal heiße bis zum tod
der mörder ihrer tochter sitzt für immer
hinter gittern
doch für die eltern ist der fall nicht
abgeschlossen
sie kämpfen weiter viele fragen wirft
die psychotherapie von howard auf
behandle ohne uns wissen was der
eigentliche vorgemacht hat also das ist
für mich völlig neu ist auch besondere
gefährlichkeit von st er hat irgendwie
auf den therapieverlauf hat kann all
diese gemacht und ich finde wie der
manager elefantenhaus mal überhaupt sich
was hat sich stets verändert will muss
jeder sagt sie und die die
gesprächsprotokolle die sind die bienen
babys oder besetzung entlasten oder
müssen wir da gesehen und und und und
also glaube manche glauben auch gut in
der marina aber doch nicht bis die
summen gefährlicher mann
wer hat den fatalen hafturlaub genehmigt
wer trägt die schuld am tode ihrer
tochter die eltern lassen nicht locker
sie holen sich unterstützung bei
rechtsanwalt hillary er untersucht
tausende von akten seiten investiert
über 1300 stunden in den fall stößt auf
immer mehr ungereimtheiten
wieso gibt es keine akten über die
therapie von howard jetzt klagt
artillerie die beamten an
ich wusste nicht was sie überhaupt dann
im strafvollzug gemacht haben
nach welchen kriterien wurde seine
gemeingefährlichkeit beurteilt wie wurde
seine psychische situation analysiert
und begutachtet alles war nicht
vorhanden so dass ich davon ausgehen
durfte
es wurde geschlampt staatsanwalt andreas
keller doppelt nach
an einer pressekonferenz begründet er
seine klage gegen die hohen
justizbeamten
die anderer meinung sein hat sich bei
mir der eindruck bestärkt da sind da
strafanstalt ein bisschen atouba
resozialisiert und therapiert worden ist
und mit dem abdruck prima nicht eben
halt auch unter inkaufnahme großer
risiken
das hat es noch nie gegeben 1999 müssen
sich justizbeamter vor dem obergericht
verteidigen im gleichen saal wo auch der
prozess gegen howard stattgefunden hat
angeklagt wegen fahrlässiger tötung sind
der gefängnisdirektor der therapeut von
howard der gefängnis psychiater der
stellvertretende generalsekretär der
justizdirektion zürich der fall ist
erstmalige fall in der schweiz sie und
es gibt ein muss lang ruby spiel das
klang ist direktorin psychiater oder
justiz die für einen tod
mitverantwortlich gemacht werden sollten
wo ein schwelbrand ausgeführt hatten
urlaub das problem damals ist sie dass
man ein auftrag hat alle gut möglich zu
integrieren und damals auf oder
fachkenntnis her die gefährlichkeit
nicht so hat keine schätze wie man das
heute macht das urteil des obergerichts
freispruch für alle angeklagten
der gewährte hafturlaub sei aus
damaliger sicht nicht fahrlässig fehler
seien passiert
doch diese sind strafrechtlich nicht
relevant
und ich hörte dass die beamten
freigesprochen wurde sind bin ich am
boden zerstört sie für mich ist das
eigentlich immer um gerechtigkeit kämpft
und handel müssen feststellen dass recht
und gerechtigkeit überhaupt nicht
zusammenpassen sondern fragt seid etwas
was ich aber kräftig völlig irgendwo
dass die sich als nachhilfe oder
stattfindet und also ich hab das wir
können ihm nach einer phase der kanton
bezahlt der familie brumann eine
außergerichtliche abfindung von 980.000
franken und gibt so eine art moralische
mitschuld zu rund sechs jahre lang hat
die mutter unermüdlich gekämpft
vieles hat sie erreicht
auch andere mütter haben angefangen zu
kämpfen gehen mit ihren forderungen noch
weiter anita shah bahn und ihre
schwester longs ihre 1998 die
verwahrungsinitiative sie stoßen auf
breite akzeptanz auch karadzic wurde das
opfer eines sexualstraftäters als
13-jährige wurde sie entführt und
vergewaltigt elf jahre sind seither
vergangen
für katjas mutter ist die tat noch sehr
präsent hier an diesem abgelegenen
bachbett sollte katja ermordet werden
nachher gesehen
sie hat sich den druck stellt und da
sagt sie können überleben
katja kann den täter genau beschreiben
er wird verhaftet er hat schon andere
mädchen misshandelt in österreich wird
er zu 18 jahren gefängnis verurteilt
die mütter stecken all ihr herzblut in
die initiative fast im alleingang
sammeln sie 200.000 unterschriften
die initiative ist radikal und fordert
die lebenslange verwahrung von nicht
therapierbare extrem gefährlichen
sexual- und gewaltstraftäter namhafte
juristen kritisieren den text verwahrung
ohne regelmäßige überprüfung das lässt
sich rechtlich nicht umsetzen
die engagierten mütter und hausfrauen
werden nicht ernst genommen zu unrecht
denn sie treffen den nerv der zeit
im jahre 2004 wird die initiative
angenommen
[Applaus]
doch heute ganze drei jahre später ist
die initiative immer noch nicht
umgesetzt
sie verstoße gegen die menschenrechte
man hat mv die initiative prüft und am
volk vorbei und volk hat je ein goldener
politische parteien und auch in kalkar
der regierung agno und jetzt haben wir
den auftrag wo englisch das ist
strafgesetzbuch umsätze der nationalrat
wo das geschafft hat hat allerdings ist
in der rechtskommission entschied das
können wir gar nicht völkerrechtskonform
umsätze und strom profitrate wir senden
aus einer blockierten situation wie die
verwahrungsinitiative umgesetzt werden
kann bleibt offen
sicher ist dank der initiative wurde die
verwahrung im neuen strafgesetzbuch
massiv ausgeweitet und verschärft die
zahl der verwahrten gewalt und
sexualstraftäter hat sich in den letzten
zehn jahren verdoppelt kaum einer wird
entlassen
die folge überfüllte gefängnisse die
gewährleistung von sicherheit für die
bürger ist eine zentrale herausforderung
für jede gesellschaft und ich glaube die
gesellschaft ist aufgerufen
alles zu tun um das immer weiter zu
optimieren
gerade was gewalt und sexualstraftaten
angeht und da gibt es eine menge
konkreter schritte die man tun kann aber
selbstverständlich ist das nie perfekt
und man wird nie eine gesellschaft haben
in der s 1 0% risiko gibt mit dem risiko
rückfälliger täter müssen wir leben
absolute sicherheit gibt es nicht aber
eine kleine gruppe extrem gefährlicher
straftäter vom profil eines erich hauert
wird immer im gefängnis bleiben
der beharrliche kampf der mutter von
pascal lohmann hat vieles bewirkt
[Musik]